le Salon de l'Automobile de Genève 93e
édition il va ouvrir ses portes au
public le 7 mars la presse du monde
entier est déjà sur place pour découvrir
les dernières nouveautés les grands
constructeurs français dont le siège se
trouve dans les Yvelines sont présents
que ce soit Renault ou Peugeot ce soir
nous avons voulu évoquer le travail des
petites entreprises des PME quatre
sociétés qui sont soutenues par le
Conseil Général des Yvelines sont
actuellement en Suisse pour présenter
leurs innovations deux d'entre elles
sont présenté sur ce plateau sont
représentés pardon sur ce plateau George
Santos Ferrera bonsoir chef de projet
pour 3A industrie et puis elle va nous
rejoindre tout à l'heure Olivier
Rosellini directeur général d'ADM
concept société basé sur Montini le
bretonneu vos deux entreprises font
partie des projets qui sont soutenus par
le Conseil Général concrètement ce
travail avec le Conseil général se
concrétise comment ça consiste en quoi
euh si vous voulez on a un appel à
projet donc qui est fait par le Conseil
général des Yvelines et suivant ce
projet nous essayons de faire
une une étude sur une innovation qui
peut
apporter quelque chose à au département
pour le pour le futur et puis la
possibilité de présenter vos prototypes
directement sur le salon exactement donc
là actuellement la société 3A industrie
est présente sur ce salon dans un
instant nous irons du côté du salon
justement écoutez l'un des représentants
de votre société nous dire un petit peu
comment se sont passés les différents
échanges juste auparavant je vais vous
laisser nous présenter le le projet que
vous présenteer actuellement du côté de
de Genève taxicol c'est le nom du projet
hein c'est un ascenseur horizontal pour
résumer c'est pas exactement ça c'est si
vous voulez taxicol est né d'une idée de
la société EXIDE donc qui est la société
qui porte ce projet vous travaillez
trois sociétés travaille sur ce projet
tris sociétés des ex exactement c'est un
consortium donc c'est cette société donc
nous sommes la société 3Ai qui avons
réalisé toutes les études de de de ce
prototype et nous nous avons la société
steel and design qui a réalisé ce
prototype on envoit justement des images
de d'application des images virtuelles
exactement donc là vous voyez une petite
vidéo qui justement actuellement est à
Genève qui tourne à Genève pourmer à qui
c'est on n'est pas dans le transport
individuel hein là non exactement si
vous voulez aujourd'hui la société EXIDE
a tenu à à innover dans le domaine du
transport donc il a choisi un moyen je
dirais peu commun pour transporter les
personnes d'un point A un point B euh
par des trajets je dirais non
conventionnels comme un bus ou autre
donc aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'horaire
il n'y a pas de trajet déterminé c'est
suivant le besoin de l'utilisateur qui
euh peut réserver à l'avance le le son
trajet et donc suivant les les
réservations ce taxic peut se diriger
sur le sur un trajet je dirais optimisé
il y a plusieurs personnes qui se se
déplace simultanément en fait oui
exactement c'est exactement c'est comme
un bus mais c'est on pourrait voilà on
pourrait appeler ça un taxi collectif si
vous voulez donc voilà et donc ce projet
est à la fois donc donc innovant je
dirais dans le domaine du transport
publicque et à la fois innovant dans le
terme où il peut se piloter
automatiquement c'est-à-dire on peut
faire une on peut rentrer dans le
véhicule sans chauffeur donc il il sera
guidé optiquement et à travers une ligne
qui sera tracée sur le sol sur des voies
privées mais un seul chauffeur si jamais
il y a un chauffeur peut conduire
jusqu'à 5 véhicules donc voilà
exactement un seul chauffeur peut
conduire jusqu'à 5 véhicules car nous
avons un chaînage des véhicules pas un
chaînage je dirais mécanique comme on
peut s'attendre à une remorque mais
plutôt un chaînage virtuel qui sera fait
à travers des capteurs qui permettront
au véhicules de se suivre et suivant le
la quantité de personnes qui auront
réservé euh donc leur place le chaque
véhicule pourra sortir du du du petit
train si on peut appeler ça un petit
train pour aller se recharger et rentrer
euh tranquillement donc l'idée c'est de
prendre les avantages du taxi de prendre
les avantages du train aussi de la
voiture individuelle d'essayer de tout
mélanger et ça donne ce projet que vous
présentez du côté du salon de
l'automobile à Genève et nous avons donc
en ligne Laurent le trionnaire bonsoir à
vous Laurent le
tririonnaireons bonsoir responsable
communication hein donc pour
l'entreprise 3A 3A industrie vous êtes
actuellement en Suisse sur ce salon de
de l'automobile quel quel bilan vous
faites de cette première journée la
première journée qui est toujours
réservée traditionnellement à la presse
aux observateurs du monde entier
beaucoup d'articles sont parus aucore
aujourd'hui quel bilan vous vous en
faites pour votre société bah écoutez
pour notre société c'est une première
journée qui se passe très bien dans ce
dans ce projet taxicol que l'on présente
donc il y a une une sorte représentation
de tous les médias français et
internationaux donc ça nous fait permet
de d'avoir une vitrine
exceptionnelle de gagner en
visibilité en reconnaissance pour notre
société et toutes les les sociétés
membres du consortium taxicol quels sont
vos objectifs pour vous pour pour le
salon c'est d'essayer de trouver de
nouveaux marchés de mener le le projet
encore plus loin voilà ouais tout à fait
le le le comment l'objectif pour sur ce
salon c'est de prendre un maximum de
contact de mener ce projet de le faire
voir le plus possible de manière à ce
que dans la suite qui lui sera donné par
par son son directeur Monsieur quat de
de d'xil et bien il puisse profiter de
toutes les opportunités de contact avec
des investisseurs ou autres qui pourrai
se présenter donc voilà c'est gagner un
maximum en visibilité en très peu de
temps quoi et vous êtes seul sur ce type
de de produit que vous avez développé
justement est-ce qu'il y a déjà une
concurrence qui s'est installée est-ce
que vous avez pu voir aujourd'hui sur le
salon par exemple ressemble de près ou
de loin à ce que vous avez développé
pardon euh oui non il y a des il y a des
il y a des transports collectifs qui
dans l'état d'esprit sont un peu surg
mais un trans comme qui alterne deux
modes bien distincts un mode d'évolution
automatique c'est-à-dire lorsqu'on est
sur une site une voie en site dédié et
bien à une simple trace de peinture sur
la sur la voie permet à au véhicule de
se diriger tout seul et puis on a aussi
la manière manuelle où on peut faire
rentrer dans le véhicule un un un
conducteur avec un joystick qui peut
reprendre reprendre la main et et faire
bouger le véhicule lorsque nous sommes
là sur une sur une route à grande à
grande circulation et non plus en site
propre merci Laurent le trionire d'avoir
été en ligne avec nous depuis depuis
Genève depuis ce salon de l'automobile
qui vient de s'ouvrir on faisait un
point avec vous pour votre entreprise on
va continuer à échanger avec le le chef
de projet qui est sur ce plateau quelle
suite pour ce projet justement après
cette présentation en Suisse donc
aujourd'hui on a un problème je dirais
de types législation qui ne qui ne nous
permet pas d'emmener ce projet au bout
nous espérons que la législation
évoluera et nous permettra de de de
concrétiser bloqué actellement parce
qu'on est bloqué actuellement oui parce
qu' aujourd'hui si vous voulez ce ce
type de projet à
véhicule autopiloté ne ne ne peut pas
prendre place dans la
législation routière voilà et pourant
l'innovation existe elle est présentée
pour le moment en Suisse George santous
Ferrera bonsoir merci de nous avoir
rejoint pardon Olivier Rosellini voilà
je vais y arriver si je mélange les
prénons c'est compliqué Olivier
Rosellini pardon directeur général d'ADM
concept qui nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau on va parler avec vous également
de de l'innovation que vous présentz du
côté de de la Suisse on parlait
transport collectif tout à l'heure là
c'est pas du tout le même type de projet
que que vous présentez c'est un valet de
parking automatisé oui absolument c'està
dire qu'on a souhaité s'intéresser aux
nouveaux usages que des technologies que
Monsieur développe à savoir on a voulu
aller à l'étape d'après on a on a déjà
constaté les blocages auquel vous
faisiez référence qui sont des blocages
plus juridiques que technologiqu
effectivement on a souhaité nous
accompagner donc les usagers sur des des
systèmes de de gestion en fait
automatique de parking pour
pouvoir dématérialiser la voiture
c'està-dire faire en sorte que la
voiture ne soit qu'un qu'un moyen de
service et qu'on ait pas toutes ces
contraintes liées au parking des
voitures on voit le petit film de
présentation alors en quelques mot
comment ça fonctionne alors le principe
est très simple c'est évidemment couplé
un système d'autopartage donc chaque
véhicule est accessible à travers un
badge RFID ou un SMS qui va permettre de
de gérer donc son accès et lorsquon aura
décidé de laisser le véhicule au bon
port qu'on aura décidé euh de de choisir
on on laissera ce véhicule se garer tout
seul et aller se charger tout seul là
actuellement cette nouveauté est aussi
présenté grâce au soutien du Conseil
Général des zblelines on en parlait tout
à l'heure puisqu'il a participé au
développement de ces différents projets
Dominique mokar est en ligne avec nous
bonsoir Dominique mocard oui bonsoir
vous êtes le PDG d'ADM concept vous êtes
en Suisse justement vous aussi pour
présenter le travail que vous avez mené
ces dernières années comment s'est passé
le premier jour de salon pour vous oui
ben bonsoir
filles et Olivier rossiveni
effectivement je viens de croiser Arnaud
mbourg qui qui vient de passer sur le
stand des ivelines du conseil général où
nous avons donc présenté notre coner de
véhicules euh valallette parking
c'estàdire que pour la 4e année on met
en fin de compte une nouvelle innovation
une nouvelle brique technologique pour
dématérialiser et donner plus de sens à
la voiture et quand je dis plus de s
c'estàd plus de service en permettant
effectivement de ne plus avoir à passer
trop de temps à chercher une place ù
aller perdre du temps pour se garer mais
la voiture aujourd'hui qui est équipée
aujourd'hui ADM concept transive est une
voiture qui a la particularité d'avoir
été transformé en électrique transformé
en autopartage et aujourd'hui
complètement robotisé domotisé pour PIR
effectivement avoir un accès directement
aux placees de parking pour ne pas
perdre de temps vous nous le dites le
gouvernement qui était présent sur place
puisque vous avez mentionné AR mbourg pu
découvrir le travail qui est mené dans
les Yvelines que ce soit votre projet ou
celui des trois autres entreprises qui
sont soutenus par le Conseil Général des
ivelines le gouvernement prête une
attention particulière est-ce que
justement les le type d'innovation que
vous
développez recueille un certain intérêt
et pourrait faire évoluer aussi la
législation on en parler tout à l'heure
sur le plateau avec certains blocages
qui quelquefois limitent la mise en
application des des des créations que
vous pouvez développer ben je crois que
vous les médias
euh eux la politique c'est un tout et on
on voit très bien que le curseur il est
il est pas loin pour changer les
comportements euh il va falloir
effectivement changer les comportements
c'est la voiture électrique à un sens
qui peut être soutenu on a modélisé la
ville de Saint-Quentin en iveline la
gare de Saint-Quentin pour essayer
effectivement de montrer que grâce à
notre système et en mettant par exemple
des é de de chez Renault et des TI avec
tway on avait la possibilité de gagner
30 % de place dans la gare de
Saint-Quentin et on est sur des projets
avec le CEA
pour la ville de Versailles où on espère
effectivement faire à la Gard de
chantier versaill exactement la même
chose un distributeur de voiture
électrique merci Dominique MOC d'avoir
été en ligne avec nous pour ce ce point
rapide concernant votre société sur ce
salon de l'automobile on va continuer à
échanger avec Olivier Rosellini sur sur
le plateau on entendait Dominique mocard
dire que le système éit en test
actuellement de transive vous le
développer vous le testez oui absolument
c'estàd que on met en œuvre un
démonstrateur qui permettra d'avoir des
applications ensuite sur des situations
en grandeur réelle ce dont parlait
monsieur c'est effectivement que la la
législation aujourd'hui est extrêmement
contraignante sur la voie publique par
contre sur des sites propres ou des
sites privés ce que sont les parkings il
est possible à ce moment-là de de
commencer à mettre en place ce genre de
dispositif mais c'est l'enjeu
aujourd'hui pour pour pour vos sociétés
qui sont présentes sur le salon de
l'automobile de faire avancer les les
législations oui c'est un enjeu de faire
avancer les législations c'està-dire
qu'il faut permettre au aux politiques
de de se rendre compte que la
technologie est là les économies sont à
la clé et et et comme de plus en plus
dans les villes on aura de moin en moins
de voiture il faut trouver des solutions
pour les usagers même chose en ce qui
concerne taxic j'imagine oui tout à fait
c'est qu'aujourd'hui sur les grandes
agglomération on est de plus en plus
contraint par la population croissante
donc aujourd'hui on est obligé de
trouver des solutions annexes et donc le
taxi est un moyen je dirais moins
contraignant que que un bus ou autre
pour pour se déplacer dans les grandes
agglomérations on va faire juste une
petite pause avant de de conclure ce
plateau on va continuer à parler
automobile le l'enjeu actuellement pour
le gouvernement c'est surtout de savoir
s'il faut taxer ou non le diesel ça
pourrait peut-être faire avancer vos
différents dispositifs et qui
permettrait d'économiser aussi de
l'essence nous sommes donc alleé vous
poser cette question allez-vous
continuer à acheter des véhicules diesel
sans doute que non j qu'il se prépare je
pense que c'est quand même assez
dommageable dans la mesure où on a
pendant longtemps favorisé l'achat du
diesel une diesel et ben en attendant s'
change pas les prix oui sinon bah je
pense qu'on fera comme tout le monde on
changera oui parce que l'essence c'est
moins performante et et que c'est plus
cher quand on fait des longs trajets
justement ça fait déjà un an qu'on
cherche une voiture essence et on n
trouve pas comme on veut donc il nous
oblige à acheter du diesel alors pour
l'instant je n'ai pas acheté de voiture
mais le diesel ça pollue et ça risque de
de provoquer des maladies graves donc
moi pour l'instant je suis slom et je
continuerai à être au samplom absolument
pas parce que déjà je suis étudiant donc
j'ai pas les moyens d'Acher une voiture
et si j'achète une voiture c'est de
l'essence parce que c'est moins cher la
pompe enfin c'est plus cher à la pompe
pardon je suis trompé mais c'est moins
cher à l'achat effectivement ça va
devenir peut-être les prix vont
s'équilibrer dans les prochaines années
peut-être une réaction à chacun ça
permettrait de booster les les solutions
alternativ les projets que vous
développez aussi exactement parce que
aujourd'hui si vous voulez l'électrique
est un une autre alternative donc à tous
ces carburants qui sont dit polluants
aujourd'hui donc c'est il faut se
tourner je dirais vers un avenir avec
d'autres solutions et c'est pour ça que
on évolue dans ces domaines quand on est
dans une situation compliquée comme
celle-ci aujourd'hui ça permet de
développer de nouvelles idées parce que
des idées émergent elles existent les
idées on parle toujours de la crise dans
l'automobile mais vous avez des idée
voulez vous en parlez ce soah oui
c'estàdire que ce qui est intéressant
c'est de se concentrer sur les usages
aujourd'hui vous avez 55% pour de
personnes qui font moins de 50 km par
jour donc pourquoi proposer à tout le
monde des voitures qui sont capables de
faire parinice le fait d'avoir des
voitures électriques correspond à la
grande majorité des utilisateurs de
véhicules en milieu urbain ou en milieu
périurbain donc se concentrer sur ce
type de véhicule sachant qu'on en est
qu'au tout début des projets électriques
et des progrès que la technologie peut
avoir que soit sur le stockage de
l'énergie avec des volants d'inertie qui
sont euh en cours de de test en cours de
de réalisation que ce soit au niveau de
la capacité de la super capacité
c'est-à-dire la capacité de de de
recharger très rapidement des véhicules
avec des dispositifs déjà chargés donc
tous les progrès sont sont à venir
projet encore à développer du côté aussi
bien de votre société ADM concept que du
côté de 3A industrie merci à tous les
deux nous parlions ce soir de ces deux
projets qui sont soutenus dans le
département des ivelines et qui sont
présentés du côté du salon de automobile
à Genève le 78 est quasiment terminé
pour ce soir juste le temps de vous
donner cette information politique vous
avez rendez-vous des samedi 10h 16h et
21h30 sur TVfil pour le premier numéro
de municipal 2014 nouvelle émission
politique de la rédaction nous parleront
forcément des enjeux de ce scrutin tout
juste un an avant que les électeurs ne
se rendent aux urnes et petit aperçu
justement avec la situation au centre
l'UDI le modem comment s'organiseent ces
deux formations reportage de Catherine
zulato B l'UDI l'Union des démocrates et
indépendants se met en ordre de marche
regroupement officiel de plusieurs
formations politiques du centre sous
l'impulsion du Parti radical offrir une
autre vision des des des choses une
autre vision politique comme ce fut le
cas dans dans le passé avec des partis
comme comme l'UDF même si aujourd'hui on
a rien à voir avec un parti un
regroupement comme l'UDF mais on a
évidemment des des des prises de
position et et des visions différentes
des partis qui existent aujourd'hui que
ce soit des partis à droite ou les
parties à gauche comment l'UDI se
positionnera pour les municipales de
mars 2014 le rassemblement présentera
des listes communes on va à l'intérieur
de chacune de nos formations puisque ces
formations continuent à exister ell
c'est pas une dissolution hein les
formation continué à l'intérieur de
chaque formation on va sélectionner un
certain nombre de candidats alors
candidats à la mairie ou candidat sur
une liste hein qui seraé mené par
d'autres éventuellement et puis ensuite
on se retrouve entre nous et entre nous
ben on fera la sélection du meilleur qui
portera le le CLE
udi le mouvement fera-t-il alliance avec
l'UMP présenté comme un partenaire
naturel on est au prémis de la
discussion avec l'UMP ça se passe très
bien moi je rencontre très souvent
Gérard Larché ou Valérie pécrè on a de
bonnes relations ils sont tout à fait
d'accord pour considérer qu'on a de
d'excellents élus d'excellentes
personnalité de notre côté il y a des
élus avec qui on travaille très bien
l'UMP évidemment donc charge à nous de
trouver une alliance intelligente et qui
soit gagnante pour les prochaines
élections répondre à de vraies
situations locales pour être en capacité
de fournir les projets que les gens
attend donc ce sera vrai là où il y a
déjà des implantations pour le reste
l'enjeu c'est pas de déclencher une
bagarre qui n'a pas de sens c'est d'être
présent avec une volonté de faire des
choses pas d'aller à la bagarre pour le
plaisir du côté du MoDem pas question
pour l'heure d'intégrer l'UDI on
souhaite garder son autonomie tout en se
rapprochant des parties du centre au cas
par cas on va essayer au cas par cas de
travailler avec eux on n'ura pas
d'accord départemental en tout cas ni
avec l'UDI ni avec l'eniste ni avec le
nouveau centre ou toutes les mouvances
qui font partie de de l'UDI aujourd'hui
mais on essaiera de travailler
ponctuellement avec avec avec ces
partieslà j'attends de voir vraiment ce
que l'UDI obtiendra de l'UMP dans ce
département qui est quand même assez à
droite pour pour pour dire quelque chose
encore une fois l'UDI n'existe pas
vraiment on verra au mois d'avril quand
ils auront constitué ce qu'ils seront en
capacité de faire dans le département
pour le modem 30 à 35 candidats sont
déjà identifiés comme Bruno Tabari sur
la ville de
Plaisir fin de cette édition du 78
demain mercredi dès 18h le point sur le
Grand Paris Express le gouvernement ao
devrait enfin rendre ses arbitrage
s priorité pour ce super métro de
banlieu je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur TV
[Musique]
fil